[Music]
Jimmy Iovine and dr. Dre are an unlikely
but powerful duo in the music industry
their twenty five year partnership
started when I ravines Interscope
Records acquired the rights to market
and distribute dr. Dre's work with Death
Row Records in addition to their musical
success this pair created the popular
headphones brand beats by dre I bet you
got some in your house right now they
later sold it to Apple for three billion
dollars with a be a new docu-series
called the Defiant ones looks at the
history of both music greats and their
stories are told through interviews with
artists and music executives that
they've worked with over the past few
decades the four-part series is directed
by one only Allen Hughes of the Hughes
brothers
the duo's behind iconic movies like
menace to society dead presidents in the
Book of Eli here's a look at the Defiant
ones shake shake we're talking my Jimmy
and dr. Dre Jimmy I mean is the
levitator Dre is the innovator work
ethic I have to work harder than the
next guy just to do as well as the next
guy and to do better than the next guy I
kid I knew that I had to be a success of
something a friend of mine put together
two turntables
I started doing this thing Jimmy Iovine
and Allen Hughes join us now at the
table I started doing this thing it's
almost like started from the bottom now
we're here about you Jimmy so I from the
bottom where I love Allen how you
started this four-part documentary
series on HBO because you start with a
crisis between the two of them this huge
beats deal Apple deal had just been
announced and then there was a big leak
about it and Apple was not happy and it
looked like the deal was in jeopardy
that's how you start the documentary yes
which shows what in your opinion it
shows the strength of their partnership
because it was terrifying when that went
down because I film almost went away too
I thought my film was gone because what
I was shooting for three weeks before
that happened yeah before he kept it a
secret rate kept I didn't know where
they were making now you hadn't told
anybody at Jimmy
then it's leaked on the Internet yeah it
was leaked than one newspaper on
Facebook yeah and you thought okay this
deals going bye-bye well I just knew
that it was a problem I knew we had a
real problem and Apple is very concerned
about secrecy you know as they should be
and it was a very difficult time as one
of the most difficult times between me
and Trey and now I'm decided to open the
movie with that I guess to show that you
know you stand you know like what I said
in it what I said to will.i.am which he
says in the movie is Dre made a mistake
it was the horse I wrote in with you
know and brought you they say we
immediately I wanted to immediately send
a signal to the audience that this is
not a fluff piece this is not gonna be a
fluff fluff piece this is not gonna be a
tribute film this is going to be a
serious film the good the bad and the
ugly tell the truth absolutely and I
learned about I learned a lot about what
the truth is there's versions of the
truth between the two of them but I
think you should set the art to let the
audience know but the the partnership
that you and Ray have because you come
from two very different backgrounds yes
very different very different but
similar in some ways you know durational
Compton I'm from Brooklyn and we both
wanted to make a better life for
ourselves right and we both somehow we
were both recording engineers that's how
we got our break you know he was a DJ
but he became a recording engineer and
so did I and what happened was is that
when we finally met and we meet in
Episode three and and we stuck together
and four and some of the most difficult
and unnerving times in the ever in the
history of the entertainment business
yeah and whoever sees the movie looks at
me and says how did you do that and you
know a friends of ours have asked me how
did you do that and I said because I
believe in him and he stayed with me
trusted me see that was the big thing
the thing it was that he trusted me and
it was
no basis for him to trust me there's so
many great interviews in the documentary
bono of course and he says there's a lot
of people that don't like him but that's
why you want him in the room for his
brutal honesty so what were you brutally
honest with bono about what's usually
the music you know like he'll come to me
it's the greatest song I ever a row and
I say well no it's not that relationship
and I'm very honest with him about it
and you know that's the part thing to be
honest about does the thing he loves and
cherishes the most aside of his family
no bono says you're like a virus that
take over the main organs of the body go
ahead charlie yeah but what we're
talking about is what and you've said
this but when we've talked about this
before with you Apple didn't buy a bunch
of headphones they bought a bunch of
heads that's why they bought well I mean
the good news is that the headphone
business has done really well at Apple
so I'm thrilled for that but the main
not the main thing but the the focus of
it right now is the streaming service
Apple music you know and I wanted to get
Apple into streaming and I wanted them
to come into the business to help the
business because there's they are the
only company that can truly blend the
technology and liberal arts they were
founded on that premise and I wanted to
do streaming there and so we needed
everything to be in one place we needed
beats I mean I couldn't be over here at
running beats and over here running
Apple music it wouldn't have worked so
we have it all there now and it's going
really well on all fronts it's going
really cute when you travel it's the
music that matters well right now it's
the future you know you know when you
travel do you notice how many people are
wearing beats and headphones you know I
still I still when I see people wearing
beads on the street which is everywhere
I go in every country I go I always
assume that I gave it to them at the
beginning I would just give them to
everybody you know whatever I do their
mom says that how I know that person and
you thought you said it started not when
they came to Dre about sneaker deal and
you said don't do sneakers do speakers
and the reason why I said that is
because fashion and audio don't
there you go Jimmy Iovine your dad once
said this about you every room you go
into is better because you're there and
everybody that knows and loves you feels
that and if I want to understand that go
look at this documentary it's knockout
congratulations
very well done very well Jimmy Iovine
and Allen Hughes it's called the Defiant
once it airs on HBO over four nights
starting July 9th that's next week